so given how things turned out in last
night's episode of agents of shield
the number one question trending
everywhere is who did Raina turn into
what is Raina and so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna do our best to answer
this question given the information that
Marvel has given us so far in the Marvel
Comics with the current running story
called inhuman
so with this discussion on who it is
Reina has become what we're gonna do is
we're gonna make this video pretty
straightforward and the reason why is
because if she is who I believe she is
that she's a very new character and so
there really isn't a whole lot to know
about her but the reason why we're
making this video is because for those
of you who are interested this actually
gives you a really good place to start
in order to learn more about her
character as Marvel reveals this
information but the front-runner as to
who it is arena has become is a woman
named Naja and Naja isn't a human who
developed her abilities as a result of
the Terrigen bomb being detonated now
the Terrigen bomb against the terror
mom's detonation was a result of an
event called infinity and infinity this
was a story that was given to us on two
fronts the first part had to do with the
builders who were perusing the the
earth-616 continuity in trying to kill
off her various planets of various
societies and so long but it was a way
for them to try to in the incursians
much in the same way that their
alternate universe counterparts were
doing but the other half of this story
has to deal with with Thanos who has
basically been tracking down all of his
offspring throughout the cosmos and
killing them off and so ultimately this
led him to a till and whereby he
confronted Black Bolt and tried to get
Black Bolt to tell him where his son was
at Black Bull of course refused and
screamed in the face of Thanos and in
the process detonated the Terrigen bomb
now what this does is this allows us to
pick up during the events of inhuman now
there are some things called inhumanity
and so on that take place between the
two but in truth those aren't really
necessary to read for the most part you
can really just jump between infinity
and then inhuman and pretty much have
all the pieces or the very least have it
explained so that it all makes sense but
the fact remains that with the events of
in human this tells us what's happened
after the Terrigen bomb had detonated
and the Terrigen mists had spread
throughout the rest of the world and so
what we find is that in issue number
five we join with a a couple of
previously established characters and in
Clinton I'm sorry named Flint and
Inferno as they're trying to make their
way to a new Attilan the new home of the
Inhumans
when they meet a woman named Naja now
Naja the way that she's introduced to us
is basically again a character that it
recently developed her powers but at the
same time she's also trying to find her
way back to new Attilan trying to find
again this city so that she can learn
what it is
be and in Demon's she can learn how to
cope with her powers and she can learn
how to be a productive member of that
society to basically just kind of find a
home for herself and again this really
ties in to Reina when did once it is
once this happened that she's taken
undertaking this transformation and
undergone terrigenesis during agents of
shield and so what happens is rayna's
powers are basically given to us over
the course of this story we learn of
course that basically she's able to make
herself invisible to a degree but the
invisibility that she has is tied
directly into her emotions in the sense
that when she's at peace with herself
she's able to basically reflect light
off of herself in such a way that it
more or less makes her invisible so it's
not true invisibility so much as it is
just reflecting light but when she's in
a heightened state of emotions when
she's negative when she's feeling kind
of down then basically she'll begin to
pulsate and so it'll have the opposite
effect of invisibility in the sense
it'll make her more visible that she
previously was now one of the other
reasons why a lot of us in the Marvel
Comics community are looking at her as
the most likely candidate for who it is
arena has become is because of her
physical appearance because her hands
have very I guess the talons of sources
since they look like the hands that
Reina had in agents of shield the
physical shape of her head the talons of
sorts maybe the the spikes are the hairs
that protrude out of her hair what we
don't know with Reina and agents of
shield is what the rest of her looks
like what her body looks like whether or
not she has a tail these things if
they're given to us over the course of
agents of shield will either go on to
solidify Rajaraja as being who it is
arena has become or else totally destroy
this theory entirely but the fact
remains that this is the front runner
this is the character we perceive her to
be
now again Nadja is an ongoing character
in in human and we're only about 14
issues in and so if what you're looking
to do is pick up on this character if
you're wanting to read more into this
character and learn for the most part
the things that we'll be learning as we
go along with Marvel's explanation and
introduction of her character then you
might want to consider jumping into this
series if not then of course as time
progresses if this theory is solidified
then I'll bring further videos in the
future once we actually get an
understanding of her origin
once we actually learn where she came
from who she was before she underwent
terrigenesis then of course I'll explain
that in future videos because right now
we don't know that we simply just been
introduced to this character we've seen
her for a few issues and that's it with
that being said we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end I know it was
very short but again she's a very new
character and so while I'd love to go
more in depth into her this really isn't
anything to go in-depth about but really
isn't a whole lot we can get into you
sir but uh yeah so I will catch you guys
hitting be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly
[Music]